making you nervous i mean it no more  than any other interrogation  this is an interview not an  interrogation would you like an  interrogation it's not i mean i don't  know the difference well one is me being  nice cop and the other is we've been bad  cop yeah i mean i think we got a pretty  good crowd over here i think everybody's  cool  look at this face everywhere  it's intimidating yeah i got you did you  learn that on the like while you're a  cop you are talking way too much you  realize that right i've never been  interrogated by a cop before i i haven't  been able to because you're talking more  than i am  how am i supposed to interrogate or even  interview if you're talking more than i  am excuse me my bad you're up